[Music]
Michelle Turner here with news on Gwen
Stefani's ex Gavin Rossdale yeah
absolutely Kevin you know Quinn is with
Blake Shelton now after her marriage
fell apart amidst rumors that Gavin had
cheated so I went into this interview
with him not really knowing what to
expect but I will say he was thoughtful
honest and raw and his only sit-down
television interview since the divorce
one of the most admirable things that I
have witnessed I've never heard you say
one bad thing about Gwen
right why would I yeah wouldn't would
never do that I mean she's amazing so
why would I think it any less are you
happy to see her happy now of course
yeah it's a sign of love fYI this rarely
happens a star being so open about their
ex and her new love did you sign off on
Blake or did you have to meet him and
know again I'm sorry
hey you said to be with nobody no no I
mean no it's like it's like obviously
nothing to do with me without Matt
Martin it's been 18 months since
nannygate and the end of Gavin's nearly
13 year marriage to Gwen the 51 year old
rocker now is doing his best to move on
you said your kids are ready for you to
get out there and start dating again
are you ready it's the beautiful thing
about love that you don't have any
control over it sort of has control over
you so you know everyone goes different
speeds how they process a divorce and
for me I'm still in the lane I want to
be which is like what about my kids and
all about working hard when he's not
co-parenting with Gwen Gavin's all about
his music his band Bush's new album
black-and-white rainbows feature songs
about love loss and hope were you
writing when you were going through your
divorce cuz I felt like I could feel
that journey writing you seriously yeah
the music I mean it's hard to separate
yourself from the most kind of
monumental thing that happens in your
life if you're an artist where does
black and white rainbow come from it's
just the idea of a new start a new
beginning and a rebirth so it's like
that idea is kind of when the rainbow
goes a bit like bit off-kilter and
you're not sure what's happening and
then boom is gonna come back
whoa colorful there you go now Gavin is
a coach on The Voice UK as well and I
asked him if Gwyn had given him any
advice on being a coach and mentor and
he said no